what if you only drank coca-cola  [Music]  if you only drank coke instead of water  you'd ingest an extra 8 000 calories a  week  this could eventually lead to your teeth  completely rotting  you might also have frequent fainting  spells and develop a potassium  deficiency  and due to all this sugar caffeine and  other chemicals you'd also experience  problems with your heart rate  as time goes on you'd also have a  massive risk of getting type 2 diabetes  and loads of vitamin deficiencies  and after years of only drinking coke  you'd eventually be 600 pounds with a  huge list of health issues  you'd take your final sips of coca-cola  and then die due to a heart attack  kidney failure or other health-related  issue  so have you ever wondered